Chúng ta sẽ đi ra
Mày ra đăng đỏ mời của em lã sái sạy
Bây giờ ngọc anh 2 mởi quay khai tại tuo quan đều tra
Sau khi bị bắt giữ, liên quan vụ việc sát thải 2 vụ nữa tại hướng in trong chiều mì bồn tôn một
Saáng người làm tấn một, ngọc anh đến công an sáng như quình hướng in để đầu tủ
Nha không nghĩ là người...
Sáng người người người người người người, để để
Thôi nhà em muốn này xin vì định
chạm đường một cú gái hay mùi tuổi, dùng rau đâm nhiều nhát khiến nạn nhân tử vòng tại chỗ
rồi dời khỏi hiện chường.
Khí đến sá lật đạo, ngọc anh gặp người phụ nữ bú mì muốn tuổi đi xem ấy
liên đùi theo, áp xác để cơ phải xa.
Khí dễ vào sinh nhà một người dân để cầu cứu, hắn xông tới đâm nhiều nhát khiến nạn nhân gác cuộc
cấp tuy nhiên lông một trắng chào chiên xe, rồi mỏ trạc.
Trạc đến khu vực phường thận thành, nghĩ phạm định mang xem máy đi cầm cố
nhưng không anh nhật, hắn mở gốc lục loại thấy có khoảng một chiệu đồng thì cầm lấy bỏ lại xe.
Cơ quan công an cho biết, các anh từng đi cầm nghiệp từ tháng 2 đến tháng 3,
hành hình khu chạm 20 bún.
Tại thời điểm bị bắt giữ, át nhàng cho thấy khi phạm ấm tính với các chất mặt tuy.